for more we turn to philip bump national
correspondent for the Washington Post
Philip good morning morning sir
we heard Paula Reed talk about the legal
ramifications of this indictment of 13
Russian nationals what are the political
ramifications it's a good question and
it's sort of hard to say in part because
we should remember this is only one part
of what the Russians are suspected to
have done during the 2016 election there
of course was the hacking of the
Democratic National Committee in John
Podesta the campaign chairman for
Hillary Clinton that isn't covered by
the indictment that came out yesterday
and so it we don't yet have a full
picture of what actually happened in
2016 this certainly does reveal that any
assurances presented by President Trump
that this entire thing was a hoax of
course are not the case this is pretty
clear evidence that something happened
there but we don't yet know what the
long-term fallout is because we still
don't have while the president and
Republicans insist that there was no
collusion we still don't know with
certainty where there isn't evidence yet
that there was the sort of collusion
that people think may have happened but
we don't yet have a full picture of what
actually went on yet the president
tweeted no collusion yesterday
does this make it that much more
difficult for the president if you
wanted to to fire Bob lower yes I mean
it's it's not clear how President Trump
is going to react to the revelations
that came out yesterday it's not clear
exactly what he wants to do with this
moving forward there are some
indications that he feels as though this
was a vindication to some extent and so
he may therefore not want to fire the
special counsel in a way that he might
have say two weeks ago but that said
again we don't know what's going to come
out we still don't know you know he is
still supposed to speak with Bob
Miller's team at some point in time
they're still saying we need to
negotiate they need to get information
from him as well which may change that
calculus but I think yesterday I think
the President sees yesterday as being
vindicated because yes well it's not the
whole picture it does suggest at least
one small picture didn't provide
evidence that implicated him what's
interesting to Philip in this is is that
yet again we haven't and we have an
indictment or an action by Muller which
we had no forewarning about I mean no
leaks on this whatsoever right it's
remarkable I think this is Washington DC
you get leaks on everything before
breakfast
Bob mulish team is you know I mean Bob
Malloy just the former director of the
FBI this is a guy who certainly knows
how to work Washington and I think
that's been revealed and you know I
think that it is a testament to his team
that we haven't had these sorts of leaks
because it suggests that they are
keeping their heads down and they're
just pushing forward on their work and
yet it's still stunning after we hear
about these indictments against 13
Russian nationals that the president
chose not to implement the sanctions
that were passed by Congress
some people were reading into Rob Rhodes
and Stein going out and issuing this
statement that he did yesterday saying
that it implies a warning not only for
Russia but he's also speaking to the
president is that reading too much into
it that he decided to speak out
yesterday it's a good question and
Rosenstein is also a little inscrutable
so you know I mean he he he was the one
that gave the briefing because Attorney
General Jeff Sessions had recused
himself from anything regarding the
Russia investigation I think there will
be a lot of political pressure on
President Trump and now that it has been
demonstrated his line all along has been
this Russia thing's hoax this nothing
actually happened here it's impossible
for him to say it at this point even in
his first tweet after the indictment
came out he basically acknowledged that
something had happened there will be
more political pressure on him to
actually take some sort of action but
we've seen consistently that his party
hasn't tried to twist his arm on things
like this so it's not clear if anything
actually will happen nope I want to talk
quickly about immigration senator tried
and failed this week to come up with a
compromise for the dreamers time is
running out I mean is there still a
chance here there's always a chance
Congress likes to wait until the
eleventh hour to actually do something
but that said there doesn't seem to be
any sort of political will to actually
get something done that will formalize
the protections that these daca
recipients it currently enjoyed it
doesn't seem to be the will on Capitol
Hill to actually do something it's not
clear the president Trump will be able
to corral them to actually get something
done
all right Philip bump thanks very much
for being with us this morning Philip